a recent Wall Street Journal poll found
most Republican voters think fighting
woke ideology is more important than
even protecting Social Security and
Medicare from Cuts 55 feel this way this
may clash with an orc poll from March it
found on issues including schools and
businesses promoting racial diversity
and acceptance of transgender people
that majorities think the country is on
the right track or not doing enough
either way whatever is considered woke
will most certainly come up among
Republican presidential candidates if
and when Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
decides to run it may even be a campaign
feature we will never surrender to the
woke mob Florida is where wolf goes to
die Florida and other states have passed
new rules recently that may be
considered anti-woke some have passed
rules against gender transition
surgeries for minors and some have rules
Banning transgender athletes from
competing in girls and women's sports
last week U.S House Republicans passed a
bill that would amend Title IX by
Banning transgender athletes from
competing in women and girls Sports at
schools that receive federal funding
make no mistake this is not a culture
War they are trying to diminish and
erase who we are as women and I will not
stand for it I'm proud to vote for this
bill marionette Miller Meeks is a
republican congresswoman from Iowa
concerns around transgender athletes
competing with women got increased
attention when University of
Pennsylvania swimmer Leah Thomas a trans
swimmer won the NCAA Championship in the
500 meter race last March she then tied
for fifth place with another swimmer in
the 200 meter last week the Biden
Administration said they want a rule
that says bans on transgender folks from
girls and women's sports violets Title
IX Thomas spoke out on her Instagram the
rule is a good start however is not
enough during this time of intense
anti-trans backlash the trans Community
needs explicit protections from
discrimination in order to live our
lives freely and equally but the female
swimmer Thomas had to share that fifth
place trophy with has been speaking out
herself there's a lots of different
moving pieces whether that be at the
state level the federal level within
specific sporting bodies Riley Gaines is
a 12-time NCAA All-American swimmer and
now spokesperson for the Independent
Women's Forum so there's lots of
different moving Parts when I'm fighting
to protect women's sports and so it
feels as if I'm everywhere but that's
exactly where I want to be as anywhere
and everywhere where I can be
contributing to ensuring that no woman
or young girl has to unfairly compete
against a male bodied athlete or share a
locker room with someone of the opposite
sex and so what I've been doing a lot of
these past couple months is testifying
at the state legislature like you saw in
North Carolina doing every thing I can
to help encourage the left-leaning
representatives or delegates
to understand how this is harmful to
women and how this isn't something
that's anti-trans or deeply rooted in
hate and I think this is something that
the Republicans could do a better job of
the language they use to talk about
these things I I have a lot of opinions
there and so I'm doing trying to do my
best on communicating my message in a
way that highlights how we as women are
being affected and how this is unfair
you noted the house bill at the
Congressional level it did pass in the
house as you noted along party lines but
it likely will not go further than that
the Senate likely won't take it up and
the White House has said the president
will veto it I wonder if that leaves you
at a state level for now like is that
the focus
I don't want to say anything until it it
doesn't go through but I am not overly
confident that it will obviously as most
people know
but there's a lot going on with Title IX
which is of course a federal civil
rights law the by demonstration they
have Rewritten what Title IX will be and
I think this will be implemented in
either May or June and this will be
detrimental to women's not only women in
sports but this would mean that men
could join sororities men could live in
dorm rooms with women men could have
full access to any restroom or changing
space on campus for women so there's a
lot of different pieces of this new
Title IX that I feel as if the general
public isn't really realizing and so
I've made it my goal while yes I am
focusing majorly on the state level in
terms of passing legislature that will
combat this issue
it's important to highlight to the
general public exactly what the Biden
Administration is doing and the exact
message they're sending to girls and
women because that message is that they
don't matter their feelings doesn't
matter their safety their privacy their
dignity their equal opportunities don't
matter Riley when it did pass the house
the minority leader Democrat Hakeem
Jeffries made a couple of points that
we've heard from others including that
this kind of legislation it bullies
trans women and girls
um I imagine that's not the first time
you've heard that that it's bullying to
ban trans women and girls from
competitions from Sports what do you say
back to that when have you been accused
of being a bully absolutely I have been
accused of every name in the book people
will call you transphobic they'll call
you bigot they'll call you hateful
they'll call you a racist for some
reason even though this has nothing to
do with race they will throw terms at
you hoping that you'll falter from your
beliefs if you're called these names
they want you to think you're guilty of
committing hate speech but hate speech
is not speech that you hate that is not
what hate speech is defined as but
that's their tactic that's what they
want to achieve they want you to be
perceived as this hateful person who has
no compassion in their heart but
speaking for myself I know that's not
true I have compassion in my heart for
every single person regardless of age
sex gender identity your race regardless
of who you are I believe everyone should
be entitled to sports these bills that
are being passed at both the state and
federal level the left loves to say that
this is an anti-trans bill that bans
trans youth from competing or trans
athletes from competing which is just a
lie this is not a bill that bans anyone
everyone is entitled fair and safe
competition in these bills and so it's
hard for me to understand the problem
other common misconceptions is they will
say that this bill would require forced
inspections of student athletes which is
an egregious violation of a student's
personal dignity
that again that is not what these bills
are doing they're referring back to a
birth certificate and or ensuring
everyone has a routine physical before
competing which is standard especially
if you're playing at the high school
middle school Collegiate level so
there's lots of misconceptions about the
bill that the left loves to push about
the people who are supporting the bill
that are simply not true it does not
make someone a bigot to understand that
there are two Sexes to understand that
you cannot change your sex especially to
diminish the advantages after you've
gone through puberty and to understand
that women deserve respect and that
women deserve equal opportunity
have you have personally had any
conversations with trans folks who
either tell you you're wrong or maybe
tell you they understand why you feel
the way you feel or have you reached out
on your own to any transgender like what
of the conversations you've had been
like
absolutely I have especially
um I'm someone who likes to remain
sensible likes to be knowledgeable likes
to consider all perspectives and So
within this lgbtq community I've had so
many conversations with with members of
this community what I've noticed
a lot of people within the LGB community
in regards to one's sexual orientation
not necessarily their sexual identity
they're really frustrated with this
movement because they feel as if they
fought for their rights they feel as if
they were finally at a place where in
many places it's almost acceptable to be
homosexual or to be bisexual but they
feel as if this trans movement this
gender ideology movement has hurt what
they once fought for and how they have
described it to me is they don't feel as
if the trans Community is necessarily
fighting for their rights they feel as
if they're taking others rights away
which is an interesting perspective and
I think it's true by allowing
trans-identifying individuals into
women's spaces and women's sports and
women's prisons and women's shelters
we're not getting equal rights they're
taking away our rights I've also talked
to a lot of people within the trans
Community who understand that being a
trans woman does not mean you are a
biological woman they know there's
differences they know that um a trans
woman can never get pregnant they know
that they will never have a menstrual
cycle they know that they have a
different bone structure there's a lot
of course a lot of differences between a
trans woman and a woman and they
acknowledge that so I've had great
conversations with people within the T
Community as well but of course you have
subsets of this or even just allies to
this community who will do everything
they can to silence you and convince you
that you're wrong for feeling
uncomfortable in a locker room next to a
male and that just makes you a bigot and
all these different things so that that
Community definitely goes both ways but
the amount of conversations I've had in
support of my stance on this issue and
we could disagree on a lot of other
things but on this particular issue
they're very supportive and they
understand finally Riley you said you
think Democrats will pay for their
stance on this issue in 2024 and I I
wonder
do you really think it rises to that
level I mean we've got a lot going on
right inflation the economy worries over
China and even still many are worried
about the overturning of Roe especially
in certain States and I just wonder if
you if you really do believe this issue
will rise to that level of mattering and
it when it comes time to vote I have
talked to so many women who are lifelong
liberals
who are seeing how the Democrats are
denying Womanhood we've now deemed it
offensive to use the term mother it's
now birthing person it's offensive to
use the term breastfeeding it's now
chess feeder and these women who again
are are still relatively sensible and
can understand what this means in the
long run for the Erasure of women
they're not okay with this and this is a
hill they're willing to die on and so I
truthfully think we have this idea of
feminism what the original feminist
movement was about right which was of
course empowering and embracing and
honoring and celebrating women based off
of their own physical ceilings and their
own uniqueness but now the left has
totally denied that so I do think the
Democrats will pay in 2024 not one of
them voted in the U.S House of
Representatives to protect women and
girls in sports which was mind-blowing
because even within the Democratic Party
um I saw a recent poll where nearly 60
to 70 percent of democratic voters don't
agree with allowing males into women's
sports and spaces and so they're clearly
not representing their party even
accurately and Riley one more finally
for you when you said earlier that you
that you think Republicans maybe need to
shift some of their language or the way
they talk about this
what would you tell them to say
I think what the left does pretty well
typically is they make things about
emotion they make things about Humanity
they have this level of compassion and
empathy which appeals to a lot of people
I think how the Republicans can frame
the conversation around this issue in
particular is the left loves to say okay
well what about the mental health of
this athlete I think the Republicans
need to come back with okay but why are
you neglecting the mental health of
women and their self-perception rather
than just continuing to say this is
about fairness this which yes of course
it's about fairness
um but there's other pieces that could
make this more compassionate because in
my experience this is something that
affected women in a harmful way not just
because of the unfair competition but
sharing a locker room with a male is
traumatizing it makes us feel as if
we're not worthy enough for Fair
competition just because we're women we
don't deserve equal opportunities and
that's that's a hard realization when
you've trained your entire life for
something and so I think the Republicans
could do a better job of combating this
compassion with more compassion and it's
more powerful coming from the
Republicans because they're speaking for
the majority whereas the Democrats are
speaking for the minority Riley Gaines
thank you so much for joining us of
course of course thank you guys